Magnus those Bishop Retreats Bishop D1
Bishop C1 just beautifully played you
must be proud that you spotted it
yeah I mean uh I it's sort of uh
sort of often the way you want to use
these Bishops that uh when he has loose
pieces they can they can be attacked and
uh the position after rookie yeah it's
already
my musician was telling me that there's
something like after Bishop D1 it's
maybe there's a defense but it's super
difficult like there's Rook the E7 but
then he's King has to go for a walk
which usually doesn't end well uh so I
think what happened here was that I
misplayed the opening pretty badly and
then
um
he um
he clearly wanted to try and exploit
that but it wasn't so easy I think it
was still equal so we went for this end
game where
I don't know I think he became rattled
after I went E5 at that point I was
happy like I have the two Bishops I
cannot lose I shouldn't really be better
but yeah the way he he played was not
not good he was trying to find like
forcing weight to draw but it just ended
up costing him instead
that's um it's a bit surprising but
um yeah I'm happy with the fact that I'm
finding finding some good moves yeah
absolutely and game three coming up is
the approach going to be wrap up the
match as soon as possible or are you
going to go for some fun
I have to go all out so
good luck